[Music]
foreign
look you have you have different kids
and each kid is so incredibly different
I'm sure you know what you do with Ethan
is different from what you do with the
siblings are there uniform things that
you that you like to sort of focus on
and and are there are there are there
nuggets or tidbits you've gotten from
from these great guests and mentors that
you talk to that that help you with that
and that Define your philosophy towards
it yeah such a beautiful question and
you're right you know the numbers don't
lie and what I can tell you is so let me
frame one one other statistic this might
scare you a little bit it scared me when
I first started but 80 of our one-on-one
time with our kids is gone by the time
they're 12. yeah I've heard that on your
show yeah it's terrifying but it also
really creates a lot of sense of urgency
and the other thing too is that I think
a lot of men or and parents just in
general we think we have 18 years right
truly what we have is 18 Summers right
but what you really have if you really
think about it yes your kids are you
know from the age of like one to five
you know there's there's a lot of
influence in brain development that kind
of thing I'm not a parenting expert on
that or a psychology but what I will
tell you that the range of Ages where we
truly have impact I believe is fathers
is six to eleven and then and then on
but those are the years that you really
set the foundation of
of how these young men and daughters
right are going to operate right and I
think what's most important is that we
create at the foundation of Father and
Son or father and daughter
its connection
it's creating an environment what we
call creating an environment of
psychological safety where your kids can
come to you and they can tell you
anything and everything
and there's ways that we can create that
and there's ways that we can decimate
that it's it's a it's an absolute skill
what a lot of people don't understand is
when it comes to raising young men right
let's just take raising young men
raising young daughters these things are
skills and what's unfortunate is that we
wing it like we just sort of like I'll
just figure it out as I go right or we
do it in relation to the the presumed
success or failure of our own parents or
whatever right we we have this image of
our our own parents as being either good
or bad right so we want to either
emulate them or do the exact opposite of
what they did exactly but what you're
talking about is approaching it like any
sort of technique or anything that's
vitally important to you got to work you
got to trade so what what are what are
some of those those ways like what are
ways that it gets decimated so the ways
that get decimated is when
um when kids are in it when your kids
are interacting with you that you blast
them with shame guilt blame pain now I'm
not saying that there's never a place
for discipline a lot of people will say
oh well that sounds like discipline it's
different right and also creating an
environment of psychological safety is
not the absence of consequences either
right so um let me give you an example
of what I'm talking about
I like to ask my kids what we call
generative questions a generative
question that's another skill most guys
um well let me just ask you this when
when when guys come home or when people
come home from work or whatever and they
see their wife and kids or whatever what
do you think is the first question that
we ask but how was your day how was your
day right that in and of itself is a
really crappy question now what I'll
tell you is the intention behind that
question isn't crappy at all totally
because we love them and we care but
there's a better way to ask right so how
was your day will always result in good
fine busy
right default question don't have to
think about it but when you ask your
kids
what's the question go ahead
what is the highlight of your day or
like what is the best part of your day
and there's a whole psychology so I'm
getting to your question of how we
create this connection when you ask your
kids what's what's the best part of your
day tell me why it was so meaningful for
you suddenly it's not how a school would
you learn how was your day suddenly
they're they're thinking what was the
best part of my day
so when they tell you they're like Dad I
had the fitness test today and I cranked
out 62 push-ups I beat Parker I'm like
dude that's a mate you must feel amazing
so I emotionally label them right you
must feel amazing you match that energy
how cool is it when we want to share
something like when you get a part right
you come home you tell your wife you're
like guess what I got the part right and
she matches that energy it creates such
a beautiful connection
that's one question
the second question is this
tell well what's the second question
what was the least favorite part of your
day what was something that like
like challenged you the most yeah and
you know you you get like an answer like
no I didn't like this or I didn't like
that yeah yeah but this is where you can
create an environment of psychological
safety so I'll show you a a good like
the good response and the response that
it's more typical right so let's just
say I say hey you know Ethan what was
what was your biggest challenge today
what'd you fail at what was the low
point of your day would you learn now I
love asking the question of what did you
fail at today because it gets us used to
the fact you know parents are terrified
to see their kids fail I mean look at
any little league game they flip out
right but fail right fail forward fail
fast right and learn that's the thing is
learn right so I I think it I think it
was you or Mason I can't remember who it
was but I'll never forget one was like
hey what was the challenge for you today
and be like
and you'll see it right
Dan
um you remember when I was sick a couple
weeks ago and I missed four days of
school yep I do
well I have seven missing assignments
right now
this is just a couple weeks ago right
seven missing assignments I have two F's
and what Ethan you know he's a good
student doesn't doesn't get F's doesn't
usually have missing assignments but was
was definitely ill like was really sick
for four days now there's a part of me
right and I where I I as a as a dad you
just want to lay on that lecture and I
was sitting there thinking like dude
I've seen you on your phone I've seen
you play an Oculus I know you haven't
been doing your work like and there's
that part of me that wants to just blast
him and be like hey we don't we don't
get apps man right we don't have missing
assignments you know you need to get
this done and just point and you're
right instead I was like okay I bet that
that took a lot of courage to tell me
that huh
so you welcome that and I said tell me
more about that I don't say why did this
happen tell me more about that
he'll explain
because tell me more is
and welcoming information why did you do
that that's accusatory and it puts us
psychological how could you do it how
could you do that what's wrong with you
right and so when he starts explaining
these things well now I don't have to
lecture and I'm like and I think the
response that I gave to Ethan was you
know Ethan now it's like the story I'm
telling myself is that you've been down
this road already like last semester and
I remember you coming through it just
fine
what did you do that helped you succeed
and overcome then
as much as I want to lecture my kid and
just tell them all this great knowledge
that I have and tell them what he thinks
he should do kids will usually tune out
and so do people when we're pointing the
finger and lecturing but when he's
explaining to me the plan
right explaining to me the plan of what
he's going to do and how he's going to
execute well now he's more sold on his
plan he's going to execute his plan and
all I have to do is be like dude that's
a great idea like how can I support you
with that like let's let's go right
fist bump well now suddenly dad becomes
a safe place to come and open up these
conversations and here's where I'll tell
you it really pays off yeah there were
consequences there right consequences
were he had to go in the auditorium and
skip lunch and and work on his projects
He had to go see a teacher for extra
help he had to stay up later than normal
there were natural consequences
but what I will tell you is there's
going to come a day
where every kid I don't care who you are
but there's going to be a 17 year old 18
year old kid who's going to go to a
party and he's going to drink too much
right or whatever they're going to do
they have that cell phone in their hand
and they have a choice that they're
going to make do I call my dad because
he's the guy I've I rep after rep day
after day he's been the guy who I can
come to with this stuff or do I spin the
do I roll the dice get behind the wheel
of the car and pray to God he never
finds out
I will tell you with a hundred percent
confidence that my boys know they can
pick up that phone and they can call me
they will not be lectured they will not
be blasted they will not be guilted I'll
be happy that they call me we might have
a conversation about it a very fruitful
one
but it's not going to result in blasting
them and punishing them but that's what
I'll tell you like so to answer your
question
kids are going to go through super dark
dark times right and what they really
need is and I'm not saying coddle your
kids I'm not saying like baby them and
they're free of consequences and
discipline there's there's natural
consequences everything
but you've got to be that safe haven for
them to be like
Dad it's dark for me right now man like
I don't know what to do because when a
kid doesn't have that that's when you
see them resort to drugs you know
alcohol
suicidal ideation all these things and a
lot of parents are like oh my God I had
no idea
[Music]
foreign
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world something I'm I'm just super proud
of and uh again grateful that you guys
tune in we've decided we want to take
things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look I already bored Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]